やりがいは人に与えられるもんじゃないよ
ね自分で見つけるもんだなま意味付け意
付けで自分自身をコブしてきたタイプだ当
に喜んでもらえること人の役に立つこと
本当にそれを信じてる心の状態っっていう
のが大事なんじゃないでしょうかね青木サ
の人生経営哲学100回聞いたら豊かに
なる
話今回はですねやりがいの正体についてお
話しいただきたいと思っていますはい同じ
仕事をしていてもやりがいを感じる人と
感じない人っていうのがいると思うんです
けれどもまこの違いは一体何によって
生まれているのかということについてお
話しいただけますでしょうか
[音楽]
うんなかなか深い話だねやりがいなうんま
昔からよく言われるのはねあのレガ職人が
レガをこう一生懸命積んでいく中である人
はまこれ給料のためにねレが積んでるとま
自分は雇われた食事ですと限られた時間の
中で積めばいいんですという人とまもう
1人は同じレガを積むなら俺のこの作品に
関しては納得の行く
やっぱり仕上げをしようという風に思って
積む人間もいると3番目の人間はねこの
建物は
これから50年100年残って自分がやっ
た作品として構成に残るものになるとだ
こういう考え方でやっている人がいるとし
てどの人が今の話やりがいを感じてるかだ
と思うんだよねだやっぱり金のために仕事
をして
るっていうのは早く仕事が終わったらいい
なと思ってしまうと思うんだよねうん
あと全くこれ別のちょっと切り口なんだ
けどまヒでね話す方が分かりやすいと思う
んだけど嫌いな勉強を8時間やるのと
大好きなゲームを16時間やるのとどっち
がやりがいがあるってことだと思うよだ
からやっぱり嫌いなことはやりがいはない
んだろうなだから仕事に対する意味付け意
付けこれ大事なんじゃないのか僕は意外と
そこはすごく意味付け意付けが得意だった
よね自分に対してもそれとメンバーに対し
てもま意味付け意付けの教育をしっかり
やってたんで同じセールスでもこの
セールスという仕事が単なるものを売る
仕事ではなくてやっぱお客様の望みを商品
を通して叶えていく尊い仕事なんだとそう
いう風に私は教育してましたよねまその辺
なんじゃないかなまもちろんなんだろう金
金金っていう金の猛者は金稼げたら
やりがい感じるのかもしれないけどさま
それは個人差があるんじゃないですかねだ
けど僕は少なくともそういう意味ではま
意味付け意付けで自分自身をコブしてきた
タイプだと思いますありがとうございます
ちなみにその仕事に対する意味付け意付け
っていうのはなんてでしょどうやったら
こううまくなっていくんです
[音楽]
そうだねまやっぱ本質じゃないの仕事の
本質を知るってことじゃないの僕はよく
研修でも言うんだけど私の仕事は研修を
する仕事ではなく研修を通して受行性が
問題解決をし物心両面の豊かな人生を手に
入れていただくこととそこに私の本質が
あるとだからもしなんだろうセミナーを
売るとかうん売るということで考えるなら
3日間の研修にするよりも2日の方が売り
やすいとか時間も朝から晩までじゃなくて
短時間の方が売りやすいとかましてや3年
で6回の最事項なんていうそういう発想は
効率からは出てこないんですよ効果性から
なんでだよねだ効果性ってどういうこと
かって言うとやっぱお客様に本当に喜んで
もらいたいという真心からあらゆる設計が
生まれてるということだと思うんだよねだ
からま実際その無理して意味付け意付け
する必要ないわけでその俺俺詐欺に意味
付け意付けはできないよやっぱり人に喜ん
でもらえること人の役に立つこと本当に
それをじる心の状態ってのが大事なんじゃ
ないでしょうかね私はそう思いますけどね
ありがとうございます働きやすさという
観点とやっぱり働きがいっていうものって
また少し違ってくるのかなと思うんです
けれどもなんかここの違いってどういう
違いだと思われますか
[音楽]
うんその自分軸なのか組織全体軸なのかの
違いって大きいんじゃないの自分中心に
考えたらトワークにしたいとか自分中心に
考えたら自由出社にしてほしいとかま
少なくとも山の線のあのラッシュは勘弁し
て欲しいとか自分中心に考えたらまオン
ラインで仕事ができた方がいいんじゃない
かとだからここが難しいところでねその
個人の尊重と全体の全体最適っていう
ところのバランスだよねだからま私は個人
でその尊重できるものはそれでいいと思う
んですよ例えば実際まうちにはあのま結婚
してえ山梨の方かなね住んでる子があのま
実際電話のフォローだとかそういうのをね
子供もいるんだからわざわざ出社しないで
その自分の家からフォローの電話をしたり
とか実際そういうことをねしてくれて全く
何もマイナスはないしかってその子を失わ
ないで済んだねだから本人のもちろん個人
のね尊重ということもそうなんだけれども
全体にとってもそれだけその人が必要なん
だという場合にはそういうことが優先さ
れるよねでも信用がなかったりいやもう家
に行ったらサボるよあいつはっていう人
だったらそうはならないと思うんですよだ
からやっぱり個人のやっぱり自主事実それ
からそのま文化を作っていくそういう貢献
の文化とか喜んでもらいたいという文化と
かそういうリタ的な自分中心ではなく
やっぱりこう周りのためにっていうそう
いう心を持った人を育てていくということ
がまグレートプレスワークスでもね今回
おかげ様でま中規模部門で念願の
グランプリを取れましたもうずっとベスト
カンパニー9年ま去年昨年は準グランプリ
だったけれどま僕別にグランプリ目指して
きたわけじゃないのでうなりなんだよね
自然にグランプリになったでもそれ僕正直
俺本当に社員のこと思ってるし本気で思っ
てるし人と比較する必要もないし人の真似
もする必要ないしで僕は僕なりに精一杯の
幸せのためにできることをしようでもその
真心とか私の思いが伝わってやっぱり社員
も期待に答えようとそういうところから
働きがいとか生きがいっていうものも
生まれてくるのかもしれない要は組織の
一員であるという喜び連帯とかで役割を
果たす個人の目標達成という軸だけじゃ
なくて与えられた役割与えられた職務に
対してでやり遂げることによって仲間に
貢献できてるというそういうところにも
やりがいてあるんじゃないかなと僕は思い
ますよありがとうございますあの
アチーブメントの働きがいがやっぱり
すごくこう多くの社員が感じている最大の
理由って何だと思われます
[音楽]
か僕の愛情でしょ俺愛してるからね本当
いや変な話ねこれ誤解がないように理解
あの聞いてもらだけど僕はね教会みたいな
会社を作りたいと思ってんのよい本当に
批判をないじゃん教会には支援だけじゃん
なんだろうノルマもないじゃんうちは
こんな会社珍しいと思うよねでもそれは
どういうことかと言うと1人1人が明確な
人生の目的を持ち目標を
持ちプランニング人生の5年10年の計画
を1人1人が持ってでその目的目標達成を
日々の実践によってこれ上司が徹底的に
関わっていきながらどうやったら昇格
できるかって一生懸命になるわけじゃん
そうすると下の人間から見たら自分を昇格
昇進させてもらえるっていうことは当然
あの報酬もある程度オープンになってる
からま簡単に言ったら見通しが生まれよね
で上は下を伸ばそう下は伸びようそういう
気持ちで切磋琢磨してるコアはまね極論
言ったけど僕の思いはあるんですよ社員
幸せにしたいと思ってるからこれはでもね
僕はすごくラッキーだったのは38年前に
選択理論という心理学に出会ったことが僕
にとっては運だよね最大の運が良かったと
思いますだこの選択理論をを使った経営
クオリティカンパニーを目指してきたから
ねそれは単なる概念じゃないわけだよ具体
的にその5つの基本的欲求が満たされる
ような制度とか複利構成だとかいろんな
ことを考えて努力してきたじゃんそれが
結局社員の働きがいやりがいにつがったん
じゃないかと思う
[音楽]
けどそうねやりがいの正体やりがいは人に
与えられるもんじゃないよね自分で
見つけるもんだなそしてやっぱり燃える
ような願望というか自分が何の制約も
なかったらどんな人間になりたいのか
どんな人生を生きていきたいのかどんな
偉大な業績を上げたいのかっていうような
やっぱりこう理想に向かって自分自身を
高めていけるそういう生き方をしてもこと
が望ましいんじゃないのかななんかねこう
与えられたことをやる義務感で
働くねばならないそういうところには
やりがいというものはなかなか見つから
ないので今言ったようなやりがいの正体と
いうのは強制のない本人の本当にしたい
ことを楽しんでできることま具体的に言え
ばゲームやってる時みんなやりがい感じる
ようん麻雀やってる時はみんなやりがい
感じるよゴルフやってる時もみんな
やりがい感じるよだってゴルフ嫌いな人
ゴルフに行ってないもんだ好きなことを
やってる時は楽しいんじゃないのかなうん
私は仕事を楽しくなるほど極めたので
やりがいを感じれる人間になったとまそう
いうことですねえ是非ね高評価と
チャンネル登録そしてコメント欄にもね
是非よろしくお願いします皆さんとのね
繋がりに心から感謝してますよろしくお
願いし
[音楽]
ますこれおかに聞た方がいいんじゃないか
俺が話すよりも働いてる人間の立場から見
てそんな風に思うよまでもね正直いきなり
今のようないい環境なったわけじゃない
わけだよまあ38年前って言ったらさ前に
もねちょっとこのYouTubeで話した
けどマンションオフィスだ
もん何にもなかったわけだからもう長時間
労働で伸びた本当にだからその頃の人には
僕は感謝してますうんごめんねとだ今だっ
たらもっとうん大切にしてあげられること
をその時には僕の能力も低かったので経営
者として32歳で創業してねやっぱり
経験不足もあったしまどうしても力不足で
豊かにはしてあげられなかった面があるよ
ね今は本当にそういう意味では社員の立場
に立ってやっぱ働きがいやりがいのある
会社を作ろうと思って努力してるのでま
それが結果的にこそうしてるのかなうん
そんな風に思いますよ